Trend Watchers take note I'm making a
shocking prediction here that I have
major mixed feelings about I think dye
culture as we know it is coming to an
end
[Applause]
and sure some may say it's high
time but its replacement may be even
more damaging than ever at least in the
wrong hands obviously we're talking
about the drug to divide the haze and
the weight loss dietitians of the world
ozempic as a great Gwen Stefani once
said
recent Oscars event
was scribed as sponsored by the popular
weight loss drug when I look around this
room I can't help but wonder is ozempic
right for me
there's a whole genre of recipes online
now labeled as ozepic soup or monjaro
lasagna and celebrity gossip videos are
moving away from feuds and infidelity to
speculate on who is secretly taking the
drug but perhaps the most telling clue
that dieting is undergoing a mega
metamorphosis is the recent Weight
Watchers and ozempic partnership so
let's talk about it because as we say
there's a lot here to unpack hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
foreign
[Music]
in today's video I'm going to be
discussing my predictions for diets
weight loss and diet culture at large
thanks in part to this new family of
weight loss drugs lycosempic but first
please read my disclaimer this is a very
sensitive topic as we will be talking
about weight loss and weight loss drugs
so as usual please feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and if you are new here
don't forget to subscribe to this
Channel and ring that Bell so you never
miss out on an episode
let me hop in here super quick to tell
you about my sponsor today ritual I'd be
working with ritual for a while now
because I really can get behind there
less is more ethos they're all about
formulating high quality supplements
with exactly what you need and none of
the window dressings that you don't I
use their Essentials for women 18 plus
which is an evidence-based third-party
tested multivitamin with key ingredients
for supporting brain health bone health
blood building and antioxidant support
and when I was pregnant and trying to
get pregnant I exclusively use their
Essentials prenatal formula you know I'm
really picky when it comes to
supplements but I really like that
ritual is backed by a visible supply
chain with rigorous testing for heavy
metals microbes and allergens and for
folks with sensitive stomachs especially
my mom's to be it has a delayed release
capsule that is gentle on the stomach
and dissolved in the small intestine
where nutrients can be better absorbed
they also have a regular multivitamin
for men a 50 plus option a posting
option and one specifically for teams
but it's super convenient because it's
delivered straight to your door so you
don't have to worry about running out
which definitely helps making taking
your supplements a big part of your team
so if you want to try out ritual for
yourself you can get 20 off of your
first month using my code Abby sharp20
so check out the link in my description
to get in on this promo today okay so I
recently Dove deep into the research on
ozempic what Govi and mongero in my
video right here and I gave my
semi-controversial maybe unexpected
personal opinions on what's going on but
in short these new weight loss drugs
have become wildly popular thanks in
part to social media and celebrities
allegedly using them to lose large
amounts of weight in a short period of
time these drugs are glp-1 agonists
which work to significantly suppress
appetite resulting in a 35 reduction in
caloric intake without impacting hunger
and they are more efficient than any
other weight loss drug before on average
we're looking at 15 body weight loss for
ozempic and wegovi and about 20 to 25
percent for monjero so how does that
compare with traditional weight loss
diets well you probably heard the
popular yet disappointing stat that 95
percent of diets fail and while this is
based on really bad science and
therefore likely inaccurate as I
discussed in detail in my video right
here the reality is that dieting will
never compete with a pharmaceutical drug
for some folks with obesity there are
just so many genetic determinants
related to reward systems hunger and
fullness cues and the propensity to gain
weight in today's environment and this
is where our Frenemy Weight Watchers
comes into play
Weight Watchers is an OG veteran in the
weight loss game they've been around for
60 years and as many of you have told me
are responsible for multiple generations
of food and body trauma but they do have
a fair bit of research to back up their
program one commonly cited study on 156
adults with obesity found that people on
Weight Watchers lost on average eight
percent of their body weight in six
months but six months in a specific
population and a very small sample size
doesn't say a whole lot to me because
who wants to just lose weight for six
months the longest term study that I've
seen quoted by WW is that 63 percent of
that weight was maintained at two years
aka the eight percent now becomes five
percent and that only 40 percent of
participants maintained that five
percent weight loss at two years
certainly not terrible but again most
people who continually spend a lot of
money on weight loss programs are
probably hoping to keep it off for more
than two years now since its Inception
Weight Watchers has always been about
losing weight through their own version
of calorie counting AKA counting Points
Plus other defining features like
Community meetings but in 2018 Weight
Watchers attempted to align with the
trend that was moving towards clean
eating and detoxing rather than overt
calorie restriction and shedding lbs so
the officially changed their name to ww
to kind of distance themselves from the
dirty d word and align themselves with
the new more trendy Wellness Community
and culture but if you're a regular
follower of Abby's kitchen you're surely
not fooled by the sneaky marketing trick
and apparently that move wasn't exactly
a slam dunk according to their most
recent quarter earnings they're down 15
percent from 4.2 million subscribers to
3.5 million from last year's report and
have lost more than a quarter of a
billion since 2022. not good but
enterozmic and other new injectable
weight loss drugs and cue the sharp
U-turn in ww's MO in early March WWE
announced that it was acquiring an
obesity Telehealth subscription service
called sequence that connects patients
to doctors who can prescribe weight loss
drugs like ozempic all you need to do is
pay the 99 monthly subscription fee
that's it
is very similar to
that's
finally a success ful business move
since its announcement WWE International
stock surged 70 percent and considering
that the demand for these drugs keeps
growing I wouldn't be surprised if their
profits follow suit but is WWE just
following the money or are they finally
admitting that maybe their program or
diets in general don't work as well as
they've been sold ww CEO SEMA cistani
described the acquisition as a
recognition finally of the fact that
there are biological and genetic
underpinnings to obesity and that in
some cases willpower alone is not enough
no Sherlock funny how the pendulum
swings and the messaging change is so
drastically when it becomes convenient
for their bottom line I think the WWE
saw that between celebrities and
influencers the current messaging is
clear as glass diets are not cool and
clean eating isn't dramatic enough to
yield Oscar level results and the
Academy Award
for Best Picture
clean eating
come on this is not a joke this is not a
joke I'm afraid they read the wrong
thing but Peter want to lose weight and
these drugs are the most effective tool
that we've ever seen and listen I'm a
business owner myself so kudos for
seeing an opportunity and jumping on it
but this does amplify a lot of the
concerns and fears that I mentioned in
my last video namely that this is going
to put ozempic in the hands of people
who do not need it and for whom may
actually be very dangerous recently
WWE's Dr Foster preemptively addressed
this concern noting we have no interest
in prescribing medications to those who
are trying to lose 10 pounds for a
reunion obviously I appreciate that
comment and I really do hope that is
true but sequence is a private obesity
membership program and one that is soon
to be backed exclusively by a weight
loss industry giant not the health
industry not medicine weight loss not me
no Hermione yo heart stop and while I
generally have a lot of trust in medical
Prof Nationals to maintain their oath to
do no harm I can't help but worry that
when membership numbers are likely going
to depend on people getting access to
these drugs amidst continual shortages
that they may feel pressure from higher
uppers to over prescribe think about it
you've dieted your whole life chased
those last stubborn 20 pounds and you
just have to pay 99 to get your hands on
a drug that will finally make it happen
more reliably than counting points or
going to a community weigh-in and if you
get turned down because you don't have
diabetes or obesity what are you going
to do you're probably going to cancel
your membership huge trigger warning
here folks who are tempted by disordered
eating tips please please please skip
ahead but I actually went through the
onboarding process to see if I qualify
and it basically asked me to self-report
my weight which was very easy to lie
about to make my BMI in the obese
category then I just had to tick off if
I had any comorbidities like
pre-diabetes diabetes peace Os or heart
disease which again you could take those
off even if they weren't true and the
only semi Safeguard in there was that I
was asked if I was diagnosed with
anorexia or bulimia in the past year I
never went any further than the
questions because you know I don't have
U.S insurance to pay but if this is the
extent of the screening this is scary I
appreciate the conveniences and
accessibility of Telehealth but when it
comes to powerful weight loss drugs I
really do worry that an app like this
could be easily abused in the wrong
hands so assuming that this partnership
does act as a catalyst for major change
in the weight loss world and these drugs
eventually do become more accessible
more acceptable potentially even more
commonplace will we ever see a weight
loss diet again well for better or worse
I wouldn't count on it diet culture has
traditionally and always will be a
battle to the badge of moral honor and
worth people always try to one-up
someone else by insisting that they are
morally Superior because they have more
willpower worked hard in the gym or said
no to delicious pizza more often than
someone else I don't think that this one
upmanship will ever die humans will
always try to find reasons to be better
than someone else I'm stronger I'm
smarter
I'm better
I am better and if body weight or size
no longer can be a determining factor
for worth how one achieved that body
will become the point on which people
are judged I always said Gwyneth Paltrow
is a perfect example of this one
upmanship one of the is notorious for
her obsession with overpriced over hyped
superfoods supplements and pseudoscience
products most of which she sells on her
website goop and as these foods and
supplements have become more accessible
at least to a subset of the wellness
obsessed Community she is like pivoted
to consuming as little food as possible
um I have bone broth for lunch a lot of
the days for dinner I try to eat you
know according to paleo so lots of
vegetables it's really important for me
to support my detox the new look of
Wellness now is to eat basically no
actual food because detox but instead to
get your nutrients from an IV drip you
can always get an IV too that's very
good in other words when too many people
can access a non-GMO Whole Food organic
diet that walks in at a hundred dollars
a day you gotta up the ante to IV
nutrition at 300 a pop so I do believe
that drugs like ozempic and wacov and
mongero are going to be life-changing
for so many people living with obesity
and diabetes I think the largest diet
company's ability to now prescribe it
for a monthly fee is a slippery slope
for over prescription abuse and massive
long-term implications for body and
nutrition Norms but I would love to hear
your thoughts on this partnership and
Olympic in general so please leave me a
comment below and don't forget to watch
my video on ozembic to get my full take
on the benefits of these new classes of
drugs as well as the fears that I have
for the future of bodies and health and
on that note please give this video the
thumbs up subscribe to this Channel and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
laughs